[موسيقى]
موجه ورديه اللون ضربت العالم في صيف 2023
فباتت حديثا الناس من الشمال الى الجنوب
ومن الشرق الى الغرب ملابس ورديه اللون
سيارات ورديه اللون مشروبات ورديه اللون
وصولا الى همبرجر وردي اللون
وراء هذه الموجه البراقه فيلم اتان من
هوليود عن باربي الدميه الامريكيه المنشا
بريق فقد وهجه عندما وصل الى بعض الوجهات
فهنا جدل عن محتوى نسوي يراه البعض زائفا
هدفه رفع مبيعات شركه ماتيل المصنعه
لباربي وهناك قرارات حكوميه بمنع عرض
الفيلم وعرائض وقعت استنكارا لما يحمله من
هدم لقيم الاسره والتعاليم الدينيه وترويج
للمثليه ومعادات للرجال وبين من وصفه
بالممت الهاتف ومن حذر منه تحذيرا شديدا
نسال لماذا يثير فيلم تجاري كل هذه الضجه
ما وراء بريق باربي في فلك الممنوع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
باربي هاي باربي
هاي باربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اول شي مرحبا بتمنى تكونوا بخير بقدر
اختصر قصتي مع باربي اللي كتبت عنها انه
دائما كانوا يقدموا لنا صور مثاليه لنموذج
لامراه كامله جميله رشيقه بتنطبق عليها كل
المعايير الجماليه
الموجوده بالمجتمع او بعصرنا الحالي هيدا
هيدا الشي كان يعمل اثر علي شخصيا بما انه
كنت مهوسه بجمع
دمى باربي مثل الاغلبيه البنات بهايداك
العصر تقريبا لعمر 15 سنه ضليتني انه
ضليتني اشتري هيدا العدد الكبير من الدمى
بكل الاصناف والانواع لان كنت عم بتماها
معهم بشكل لاواعي يعني بالواقع كنت فتاه
صغيره انه سمينه شوي بتعرض للتنمر
باستمرار بسبب وزن الزائد ويبعدوا عني
رفقاتي لانه الطفل البدين عاده خاصه بين
الاطفال هو طفل غير مر غوب فيه لانه بمثل
الشيء هم اساسا ما بيرغبوا يشوفوه او مزعج
لنظره سواء نظرهم كاطفال بعدهم عم يتشربوا
هذه القيم الاجتماعيه او او غيرها تفضلي
مهاد يعني هربتي الى باربي يعني من الواقع
التنمري باربي كانت ملجا في ذلك الوقت
اليوم كيف تقربين هذه الدميه وهل شاهدت
الفيلم مؤخرا فيلم باربي
بالتاكيد شفتوا الفيلم اول ما نزل يعني
اكيد المفاهيم بالنسبه لالي كتير تغيرت من
وقتها لليوم لانه اكتشفنا كتير اشياء
بينت عكس الاشياء اللي كنا متخيلينها
بلعبه باربي ولو كانت لعبه باربي باربي
بالنسبه لنا بهذاك الزمن انه هي لعبه هي
مجرد لعبه فقط لا غير بس الواقع كشف لنا
غير هيك انه لا ورق لعبه باربي في الكثير
من المعاناه وانه حتى نحن منا متشابهات
بمعاناتنا كنساء انه في عنا طبقات
اجتماعيه مختلفه نساء فيها بتعاني بشكل
مختلف عن طبق الطبقات الاجتماعيه الاخرى
كمان الاعراض الاعراق بتلعب دور الجندر
تبعنا ما رايك بالفيلم باختصار نهاد
هلا الفيلم للصراحه بيحمل مزيج ما بين
السلبيه والايجابيه انا بفضلكم عم بلش
بالاشياء السلبيه بغض النظر انه اكيد انا
ضد منع الفيلم لانه هذا الشيء يعني
سنتحدث عن المنع بعد قليل ولكن بشكل عام
انت يعني كنت
رايت ما هو ايجابي وما هو سلبي
طيب خلي التفاصيل بعد قليل لنتعرف على
الضيوف على بقيه الضيوف واعود اليك اوكي
في الاستوديو الصحفي والناقد السينمائي هو
حبشيان اهلا بك وفيك اثر تصريحات لوزير
الثقافه اللبنانيه ومحاولات من قبله لمنع
عرض فيلم باربي في لبنان اطلقت عريضه
وقعتها اكثر من 100 شخصيه عامله في المجال
الثقافي والاعلامي والفني اللبناني
للاعتراض على محاولات المنع هذه لكنك في
المقابل كتبت في النقد السينمائيه للفيلم
فعنوه باربي سلعه باليه في تغليف باهر
وحصد ايرادات كبيره برايك لماذا اثيرت كل
هذه الدرجه حول فيلم باربي
اولا لانه في رفض لبعض المفاهيم الموجوده
بالفيم خصوصا من قبل ناس ما شافوه بس
سمعوا عنه مثل الوزير الثقافه اللي هو
بالنهايه وزير ما لا يمت الى الثقافه بسله
يعني وهو
بس عم يعني عم بطبق او ما هي هذه المفاهيم
التمكين المراه
النسويه وكل هالقصص اللي هي يعني
بسقافه اليقظه او السحوه مثل هلا بقولوا
بامريكا الوك ووك فاكيد بالنسبه للون
يشوفوا الرجال بهالطريقه هاي ولا يشوفوا
المراه بالطريقه فاكيد كل شيء خارج النمط
التفكير تبعهم بيحاربوه وخصوصا انه بلبنان
يعني
نحن محكومين بمجموعه ناس
يعني احزاب طائفيه مذهبيه
في شويه قانون بعد موجود بلبنان لما شافوه
الرقبه وشافوا الامن العام فما في ما في
ولا ولا شيء بخالف القوانين محطوطه من
زمان هي قوانين محطوطه من كثير زمان
بس بنفس الوقت يعني ما فيهم يمنعوا شيء
اذا مش مخالف للقوانين
كلام كلام وزير الثقافه ما بيكفي انه
يمنعوا فيه بالنهايه ونحن بلبنان بنلعب
بها التناقضات يعني اذا مجموعه ناس
كانوا ضد فيلم تطلع دائما ودغري مجموعه
ناس تانيين بدافعوا عن الفيل فبنستفيد
ربما كناقه سينمائيه يعني بالنسبه اليك
الفين مسطحيه يعني وجدته سطحيا يعني في
تجاري
انا
بافلام بين تجاريه وفنيه ابدا يعني
كمان مهم يعني بالنهايه كل شيء تجاره او
مشي تجاره بس بالنسبه لالي اكيد الفيلم
اولا يعني بمزعج بين الكوميديا
يعني ما فينا ناخذوا هالقد على محمل الجد
هو المشكله الفيم انه لبسوا عليه او حتى
ما بيتحمل هالقد يعني بالنهايه
لا يحمل كل هذا الجدل الذي الجدل اللي
حاصل باوروبا يمكن لانه في نقاش جدي حقيقي
حول قصص حول معنى الصور وابعاد
ابعاد توظيف شركه شركه دوما لا تعمل فيهم
هيدي من هالجانب فينا نحكي عنه قد ما بدنا
بس الجدل موجود عندنا في العالم العربي
اللي هو عبسي يعني تخيلي مثلا بلد مثل
الجزائر كانوا سامحين فيهم ونعوه وفي بلد
ثاني لبنان كانوا سمحوه يعني عايشين حاله
من
اللي مش مش مفهومه يعني شو هي وخصوصا مش
شايفينه للفيلم يعني عم بيحكوا عن السمع
نعم وقد واجهتنا الكثير من هذه القصص عند
اعداد هذه الحلقه اتصلنا باشخاص لديهم
ربما اراء حد اذا هذا الفيلم ولاحظنا انه
يعني هؤلاء الاشخاص لم يشاهدوا الفيلم
اصلا يعني كتبوا عن فين دون يعني مثلا
قالوا انه في حكي عن المثليه في حكي عن
انه تفكك الاسري وهذا كله مش موجود بالفيم
جايبينه من ما بعرف من وين مخيل تبعهم
يعني شغله غريبه كتير ابقى معنا
عبر الاقمار الصناعيه صانعه الافلام
والصحافيه
فيديوهات عن فيلم باربي عن وانتهاء باربي
من الاستهلاك الى النسويه نقاد كثر وكتاب
من كل العالم وصفوا فيلم باربي بكونه
الفيلم النسوي لهذا القرن هل توافقين
ولماذا
لا انا ماني مع انه نوصفه انه هو نسوي ميه
بالميه الافكار يلي تقدمت بالفيلم كانت
افكار بعضها نسوي وبعدها خليني اقول صل
على النسويه او حاول اظهار نسويه بشكل غير
صحيح اذا بتحبي فينا نفوت شوي بالتفاصيل
ونفند هذه الافكار وحده وحده ممكن ان
تعطينا مثال يعني لمن لم يشاهد الفيلم
اتفضلي
اوكي على سبيل المثال ببدايه الفن الافكار
النسويه اللي انا حبيتها انه شفنا حفله
كان بهاي الحفله في اشكال مختلفه لباربي
كان في تنوع بالاجسات تنوع حتى بالوان
البشره كان في باربي مقعده عم ترقص هذا
الشيء كسر للنمطيه وشي كتير ظريف برايك
كمان كان مثلا مشهد المطارده اللي هو
يعتبر احد اعمده مشاهد المتعبه افلام
هوليود المطارده بالسيارات هالمره كانت
اللي عم تقود السياره امراه وقدرت انها
تنتصر باعاده بيتم اظهار المراه انه هي ما
بتعرف تسوق السياره وهي التفاصيل اللي
احنا بنعرفها
افلام يعني فيها فيها سيارات تقودها نساء
فيهم
يعني انت بالشكل الاعجاب عن اين وجدتي
التسليع اللي شفتها ايجابي
الاشياء اللي ما حسيتها ايجابيه انه لما
انحكى عن عالم باربي الم اللي هو انه
المراه في هي عم تقود كل المجتمع والرجل
مهمش هاي الفكره هي بعيده عن النسويه نحن
بنادي بمجتمع فيه عماده المراه وعماده
الرجل فيهم مساوات بين الطرفين ما بيتم
تهميش اي طرف فيه فقط
والمشاهدين هي يعني هناك فكره في الفيلم
حيث يتم يعني تبديل الادوار يعني تبديل
ادوار السلطه يعني هناك نرى النساء في
عالم باربي يحكمنا ومن ثم نخرج الى العالم
الحقيقي لنرى انه عالم ذكوري ويحكمه
الرجال طيب يعني انت بالنسبه اليك هذه
الفكره تتناقض مع النسويه ساعود اليك الى
ابقي معي هنا في استوديو ايضا ارحب
بضيفتنا الاخيره نشطا النسويه والكوريه
اميمه اهلا بك اميمه جدل كبير بين
النسويات والنسويين داخل يعني كما يقال
البيت النسوي حول محتوى فيلم باربي في هذا
الصدد هل تعتبرين ان لهذه الدميه ربما
حظوظ بان تمثل النسويه في العصر الحديث ام
ان مصنعيها يحاولون الاستفاده من قضايا
النساء الحقوقيه ومن من موجه النسويه التي
تعم العالم من اجل رفع المبيعات
هو يعني دميه باربي مش دميه جديده دميه
ظهرت في 1959 وكانت موجه النسويه تاريخ
تقريبا في الموجه الثانيه للنسويات
الاوروبيه وشمال الامريكيه
وحاولت ساعتها انها تكون رمز من رموز
النسويه
واليوم باربي قبل هذا الفيلم كانت تعتبر
رمز من رموز
الذكوريه ونرمز من رموز تكريس الصوره
النمطيه للمراه النحيفه الشقراء
ذو الصدر الكبير يعني واليوم اظن ان هذا
الفيلم
يحاول جعل باربي نسويه لان اليوم اصبحت من
الموضه اننا نكون النسويات ولكن نسويه
نسويه بطريقه سطحيه جدا يعني بالنسبه
النسويه السطحيه هي التي اظهرت في الفيلم
تماما يعني نسويه سطحيه هناك غسيل وردي
وغسيل
بنفسجي اي استعمال نسويه
لبيع اكثر
[موسيقى]
هناك هناك ارتفاع بالنسبه 56 بالمئه في
المبيعات لشركه ماتل وايضا لشركه يعني
التي تبيع الاحاديه او يعني التي ظهرت
لما بتشوف انه في موضه جديده اكيد هي مش
موضه نسويه يعني بس انه بتقدر توظف
وتستفيد من هالموجه اكيد بتفوت فيها مش
انت تربح مصاري بس هي بالنهايه مثل ما
بيقولوا
الفوتوشون
يعني من اجل تغيير من اجل عدم التغيير من
اجل تغيير هي تبقى موجوده بتغير جلدها
مشان يعني تواكب
[موسيقى]
هذا الامر كله مش مش الاعلام مش انت ولكن
ايه فهمت فهمت ما تقصد ولكن اليوم المشكله
على موضوع توجه الشركه نحو النسويه انه هو
ما بدا من هذا الفيلم هذا التوجه بدا من
عام 2015 لما الشركه تعرضت لخسائر كبيره
بحجم مبيعاتها كونها عم تروج لهذا شكل
باربي اللي حتى البطله الفيلم قالت انه
انا باربي الكليشي اذا بدنا
نمطيه
ان النمطيه بهذا المقاييس الجمال فعام
2015 تم اصدار اشكال متنوعه من الباربيات
وقتها عملوا هاي باربي الكيرفي باربي
الالوان مجموعه
تمام حتى عملوا مجموعه من النساء الملهمه
تعملون باربي فهذا التحول بالشركه هو بدا
من عام 2015 مو هو وليد الفين طيب اميمه
تريدين ايضا يعني اضافه ان في نقطه مهمه
كمان في الفيلم انه
فيلم يعتبر ان
المثاليه النسويه في عالم بلاستيكي واحنا
واحنا اليوم كانسويات
نعتبر انه النسويه ممكنه في عالم
حقيقي اين هناك الرجال ونساء وهذا كان
السؤال هل هل اخرجت باربي من علبتها كلعبه
يعني ام لا في هذا الفيلم اخرجت الى
العالم الحقيقي لتكون نسويه حقيقيه ام ظلت
بلاستيكيه وهذا هو النقاش من العلامات
التي انا لا اعرف ذلك العالم ليس هناك
ليس هناك
مش مثير اي فيلم يعطي جواب يعطي وليس عمي
العناصر مشان نحن نقدر نستنتج من هون ومن
هون شوي لانه كمان عمل توازن بين كذا
مدرسه
هذا النقاش المدارس الفكريه موجود في
المجتمعات الغربيه اثر اطلاق الفن مشكل
اليوم ان هذا الفيلم تعرض للمنع في عده
دول عربيه وغير عربيه منها الجزائر الكويت
سلطنه عمان في مجله محاولات منع ايضا في
لبنان في مصر في البحرين
هو باكستان
مقاطعه في باكستان واليابان دعوات ايضا
لمقاطعته في تونس والسعوديه وغيرهما في
المقطع التالي عينه من اراء الشارع
لمواطنات ومواطنين العالم العربي حول
مساله المناع نستمع معا
لعالم بتطفي على تروح تحضروها المنع لن
يفيد في شيء لان من يرغب في رؤيه اي حاجه
يستطيع ان يبحث عنها في اماكن اخرى
كل دوله حره لاني في دول بتبقى متقدمه فهي
عندها وعي كافيه ان الحاجات دي مجرد تصوير
او دي حاجه اوبشن مفتوحه عندهم
تمنع حسب رايي اللي وقتي تبدا افلام تخل
بالاخلاق خصوصا
مجتمعات مسلمه مجتمعات محافظه شوفوا
الحكومه سمحت باشي مش مقبول نهائيا
بعاداتنا وتقاليدنا
بسبب تجهيج بناس كثير معينه موجود عنا
مجتمعات
الاجنبيه بتنزل مثلا نشاهد عن المثليه
والكلام ده فده غلط احنا مجتمع عربي وشرقي
فما ينفعش المشاهد دي الصبيان يمكن يحبه
يحطوا اكل ادورسوا حلق وما بعرف كيف
يعملوا هالحركات يتاثروا فيه والبنات نفس
الشيء بالنسبه اذا هي هالقد شخصيتها
بصيروا كتير
مسيطرين وهيك لا ممكن لو هو في مشهد يضر
الاطفال لا يمنعوه انت بتمنع الناس
لازم يعني كل الدول تكون موجود فيها يعني
هو كثير قريب للواقع يعني مش انه كتير
بعيد عن الواقع اللي احنا فيه ميهات سابدا
معك بمساله المنع هذه اليوم كيف تقربين
هذه المساله انت كشابه نسويه وهل تعتبرين
يعني ان كل هذه الضجه والمنع فعلا يعني
مستحقه في مساله فيلم كفيلم باربي
الصراحه اول شيء بيخطر على بالي بمساله
المنع انه في كثير افلام ومسلسلات منشوفها
يعني سواء على الشاشه اللبنانيه او على
الشاشه السوريه يعني
مليئه بكميه من العنف لا تصدق هذه كل يوم
عم الاطفال والاشخاص بشكل عام نساء ورجال
وعم تترسخ بدماغهم يعني من قتل لاغتصاب
لغيره من الاشياء فما بعرف انه كيف ما
بينتبهوا على هذا الاشياء وبينتبهوا انه
باربي حط غير عقول الاشخاص او حتاثر على
الاطفال انه اذا هذاك مليء بالعنف اللي هو
الشيء اللي حيكون عم بياثر بشكل سلبي على
على المجتمع بشكل عام فما بشوف القرار الا
انه هو قرار قمعي مثل اي شيء موجود
بالمجتمع يعني يعني خاصه بالمجتمع خاصه
اخر فتره الاشياء اللي عم بنشوفها من
حملات طمع وللحريات خاصه حريه التعبير
يعني طيب ساتحدث معك عن الاستخدام السياسي
تحدثت منذ قليل قلت في الفيلم هناك ربما
بعض الرسائل المبطنه او الافكار التي قد
يعتبرها كثر غربيه او مستورده او لطليق
بمجتمعات لديها كما يقال عادات وتقاليد
معينه اليوم برايك هل المنع هو استخدام
سياسي لهذا النوع من
بالنسبه لالي انا مثل ما انا عم شوف سلطات
عم تمنع وهي عارفه ميه بالميه اي شخص
بيقدر يشوف هذا الفيلم اصلا صار موجود باي
طريقه ممكن ينزلها على الانترنت
المواقع القرصنه بس هو يعني الشخص اللي
بده
يجرب يمنع عم بيقول انه انا موجود هون انا
وصيه عليكم يعني هو تقريبا شي رمزي يعني
عم بيقول رمزيا انا قادر اعمل قادر
افرجيكن اللي انا حابب افرجيكم وقادر امنع
عنكن
شريحه من الناس في هذه المجتمعات ربما لا
يعني لا تتفق مع المفاهيم او مع الصور
التي تقدم في فيلم مثل فيلم باربي اكيد بس
ما في ولا انسان مجبور يروح يشوف فيهم
بالسينما يعني انت تروحي بتدفعي مصاري
بتفوتي بتشوفي فين عرفتي كيف الشيء الوحيد
اللي ممكن يعمل عليه رقبه هو تصنيف العمر
بس يعني 18 سنه 16 سنه 12 سنه ما
اي طفل او اي شيء الكلام اللي انقال يعني
بهالسياسي مثل ما انت عم تقولي كل شيء قال
عن الاسره وعن الايام اي ايام بعدين في
بدايه الفيلم حيث تقوم فتيات صغيرات
بتحطيمي اللعب التقليديه يعني
الرضع
الدميات الرضع او رضعات بتحطيم رؤوسهن
بتكسيرهن واخذ هذا الامر الى منحه على انه
تحرير للنساء على انه دور النساء ليس في
الامومه مثلا هذا ما قيل عن الفيلم
اسقاط مبالغه سخيفه اكيد مش كلامي كذا
بس بعدين اذا تحريرت حتى ما حتى لو تحرير
لازم يكون في شويه تحرير كمان على كل شيء
عم نعيشه يعني هي اقل شيء يكون في تحريز
بالنسبه لالي بس انا اكثر شيء جمله صغيره
بس بعد اكثر شيء انا بجنني بهذا الموضوع
لانه دافع عن افلام انا مش مقتنع فيها
ابدا بس بصير معها لما هني
مع حوريه الاختيار يعني يعني نشاهد ما
نشاء ولا نشاهد اكيد هن مش عم بيمنعوا
سينما هن بس
شو بتشوفوا الاء عندي سؤال في هذا الصدد
اليوم قد يقول
وتقول الكثيرات وكثر انه يعني خاصه في
الدول العربيه لدينا ما يكفي من المصائب
من الاولويات هل الحديث اليوم عن فيلم او
منع فيلم من عدم منعه هو اولويه ولماذا
نذهب الى النقاش في هذا في هذا الاطار ولا
نناقش بامور اكثر جديه ما رايك بهذا بهذه
الاراء
مع الاسف الافكار صارت منتشره مات عنا
رفاهيه انه كل حدا يختار الافكار اللي بده
يحكي فيها بمجتمعه صار في تريند عالمي هو
اقوى من كل المجتمعات واقوى من المشاكل
الخاصه بكل مجتمع عم ينحكى فيه يعني
الموجه الموجه الترويجيه اللي رافقت باربي
هي سبقت الاخبار وسبعه اللي عم يصير
بسوريا واللي عم يصير بلبنان اللي عم يصير
بكل الدول العربيه انفرد علينا انه يصير
هذا هو الحديث تبعنا يعني ما معنى هاي
رفاهيه الخيارات شو بدنا نختار مواضيع
بهذا العصر وبالتالي انت بالنسبه اليك
يعني هو هو امر غير مقبول اليوم ان يتم
منع فيلم ونحن مفروض علينا ان نتحدث
بالنسبه
منع فيلم هو يعني براي الافكار الفنيه
والثقافيه بتمنع بمجتمعات بتتصل بثلاث
صفات اول شيء فساد المسؤولين ثاني شيء
النفاق الاجتماعي العالم تحكي شي ومن تحت
لتحت تعمل شي ثالث شيء العنف وهي الافكار
الثلاثه
شفنا شو صار بلبنان من كم يوم
الاعتداء على الثلاثه الاعتداء على احدى
الحانات في بيروت
تحتها حجه انها حانه للمثليين والمثليات
واعتم الاعتداء على الناس ونعم
طيب يعني وزراء الثقافه وزراء الاعلام هم
لازم يطلعوا من هاي يفهموا انه هذا
المجتمع الابوي اللي بيقدروا هن يتحكموا
فيه بافكار العالم وشو يحضروا وشو ما
يحضروا هو انتهى لانه يعني شاقوا ام ابوه
احنا بعصر الانترنت كل شيء فيه مباح بس
للاسف شفنا انه في ناس كمان يعني بيدافع
عن الخيارات هايدي ناس مغسولين
حتى شوفنا
اليوم اليس كذلك انا رايي اكيد
[موسيقى]
من الناس في العقليه ولكن يعني اشتغلت على
العقليات واخذت وقت كتير للطيب يعني
وايضا انا اظن هذا المنع هذا الفيلم في
هذه الدول كمان انا بالنسبه لي رساله لقول
نحن يعني الهويه العربيه الهويه الاسلاميه
بعيدين عن الامبرياليه الامريكيه وبعيدين
عن هذه يعني المنظومه وهذا يعني برايك هل
يخيف فيلم كاباربي يخيف هذه هذه
الانظمه الموجوده اجتماعيا وسياسيا
واقتصاديا ام انه يستخدم هذا الفيلم من
اجل ترسيخ هذه الافكار يعني هل هو مخيف
وهو ليس مخيف الفيلم ليس مخيف هذا فيلم
اداه
للتفكيرنا بمن له السلطه تفكيرنا بترسيخ
يعني لترسيخ هذه الافكار وترسيخ ان نحن
مسلمين عرب
محافظون
يعني انا لا اظن ان هذا الفيلم مخيف انا
حتى يعني الناس التي منعت الفيلم لم
يشاهدوا الفيلم يعني
كان هناك هاشتاج مثلا انتشر بكثره احذروا
فيلم باربي تم التحذير منه ولكن عندما
تفند هذه المعطيات تجد ان هناك الكثير من
الاخبار الكاذبه التي اثيرت حول الفيلم
يعني
انه مخيف لماذا انه يخيف لماذا يخيف فيلم
بخوف
انا برايي انه اي فكره طالما انها لا تدعو
للعنف اتركوها تروح تنطرح بالسوق مثل ما
هلا نحن عم نعمل جبنا الفيلم عم نحكي شو
فيه سلبيات عم نحكي شو فيه ايجابيات
وبالاخير كل حدا بيحب يتبنى فكره بيتبناها
واللي بحسها غير صالحه بس لما تكون في
مجتمع خايف من فيلم ومشيطنه هالقد يعني
اذا بس كتبتي فيلم باربي على يوتيوب
الفيديوهات المحتوى العربي اللي عم يشيطن
هذا الفيلم شي مخيف بحسسك وكانه فيلم يدعو
الى القتل يعني
على طول
يعني تماما تماما هايدي قررتيها كثير انه
اي مناعه هو ترويج بس بالنسبه لالون يعني
حتى مثلا
بمؤخرا بايران في مخرج كمان لانه انعرض
فيه موبيكان يعني عملت ضجه عالميه كبيره
لو مرقوه لخلوه لو خلوه ترك
مش الناس يشوفوها اكثر بس مش هذا الفيلم
يعني
المشكله انه اليوم في دولنا في دول
المنطقه الناطقه باللغه العربيه هناك
مشاكل كبيره جدا يعني مثلا لبنان اليوم في
يعني هناك ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره من الحروب
في المنطقه هناك في المنطقه صراعات اهليه
هناك نعم طبعا فهو يعني منع الفيلم اداه
لقول ان
السلطات او الانظمه ما زالت تحكم ما زالت
موجوده ما زالت لها يعني في هنالك تحكم في
الوضع
علما انه نحن اليوم نعرفوا ان هذه الانظمه
لا تتحكم باي شيء يعني طيب اليوم هناك
مشكله في هذا النقاش يعني وساسال مهاد
اليوم عندما نفند الفي من ناحيه معينه
يمكن ان يقال يعني كبار النقاط قالوا انه
تسليع ربما الراسماليه التي تروج اليوم
لقيم معينه من اجل ان تبيع هذا ما يقال
طيب عندما نقول هذا الامر عن فيلم ونعترض
لاحقا على
ان تقوم دوله باعتباره ربما محتوى مستورد
لا تريد ان تفعل
ما رايك يعني هناك نوع من التناقض في مكان
ما لا
هو منو تناقض بقدر ما هو احترام حريته نحن
ما في ما فينا نيجي نقول انه ما فينا ما
فينا نشوف او نحضر فيلم او اشخاص يحضروا
افلام معينه لانه ما عجبت معاييرنا نحن لا
هون
تنضمنت خانه القمع اما اذا كنا عم نحكي من
منطلق الراسماليه انه الراسماليه بما تحوي
من شركات وصناعه افلام قادره على تحويل اي
قضيه حقوقيه وانسانيه لسلعه لتحقيق
الارباح لصالحها يعني
انه هذا الشيء هل حيفيد النساء فعليا على
ارض الواقع انه لا هنلاقي انه بعض النساء
عايشه بعالم مثال هيك عنه او منقطع عن
العالم الواقع بهيدي الحاله فهي النقد
بيكون من هذه الجهه والنقد هو بيجي بهدف
البناء يعني اكيد مش بهدف
التحقير او الهدم بمطرح من المطالح
يعني بالكتاب او بالاعمال او بالانتاج
الثقافي او الفني طيب
على على السيروره اللي بتمشي فيها هذه
القصص ايضا يعني من الاشياء التي تقال انه
اليوم عندما نعرض فيلم كهذا امام الجمهور
العريض الافكار قد وهو امر ايجابي احيانا
حتى لو كان الفيلم فيلم يعني ترفيهي يمكن
ان يبث افكار بشكل غير مباشر لدى جمهور لا
يهتم بقضايا معينه
هل هذا صحيح ليتاثر الجمهور اليوم بهذه
الافكار بهذه الطريقه التي تقدم يعني انه
امر خطير جدا انه هناك بث لافكار معينه
اكيد بتاثر كل شيء بتاثر باثر علينا
حوالينا كل شيء نحن ماشيين بالشارع بنشوف
اشياء اذا هناك سبب للخلف ولكن ما في حدا
انا قاعد على راسي هو له حق يقول لي تاثر
او ما اتاثر هي السلطه مش معموله لهالشية
هي معموله لتمشي
امورنا الحياتيه مش تتدخل بنوايانا او
بتاثيراتنا هيدي قصص بتصير بالمدرسه
بالعائله هني هول اللي بيرشدوا الانسان
عرفت كيف بس على كل حال هذا الفيلم مش من
النوع اللي يعني كمان ما نصور انه اذا
واحد شافه راح يروح يقتل حدا اصلا حتى
الافلام العنيفه تاكدنا منها مش انا يعني
تاكدت يعني في نظريات كانت بتقول انه اي
انسان اذا شافها ممكن يروح يقتل او شيء
هيدي مع الوقت اثبتت انه علميه يعني مش
مضبوطه
هذا الخصوص بخصوص تاثر بظن انه التاثر هو
بصير بطريقه يعني مثل ما ذكرتي حضرتك
بطريقه غير مباشره بياثر باللاوع يعني على
سبيل المثال بهذا الفيلم بقلب الفيل نفسه
كانوا حولوا النساء يلي عم يشوفوا الفيلم
لزبائن يعني اللي احنا كنا عم نشوف الفيل
نحن كنا زبونه
للاحذيه وللاشياء يلي عم تحاول تلبسها
باربي هاي اول هيك ممكن هيك ممكن يكون
التاثر لانه لما تكون عم تعملي
النقطه الثانيه كان في مثلا شغله هي
المانس بلانك لما
تفوق الرجل يعني لما صار اذا صح التعبير
خليني استخدم كلمه الانقلاب الذكوري بعالم
باربي وصاروا الرجال هم اللي عم يسيطروا
على هذا العالم شفنا مثلا انه الرجل هو
اللي عم يعلم المراه كيف تعمل كل الاشياء
اللي كانت بتعملها مثلا من قبل فهي هاي
النقطه مثلا ظلت معلقه بذاكرتي انه هذا
الموضوع انه في عنا مصطلح اذا فينا نقول
هو عجرفه الرجال او الرجل المحاضر هو اللي
بيستلم الحديث وبصير يعلم النساء اللي
حواليك الاشياء
تتصور بالفن بطريقه غير مباشره هون بصير
اللعب على انه العالم تتاثر بشو عم يصير
بالفلم او بالدراما لانه الدراما من
الواقع والى الواقع كمان طيب شكرا لك الاء
اميمه سؤال يعني اليوم مخرجه الفيلم قالت
انه فيلم نسوي هل يمكن ان نقول بعد هذه
الموجه الورديه التي عمت علينا جميعا انه
الباربي تحولت من دميه الى ايقونه نسويه
اليوم بالنسبه الى الشابات والفتيات
الصغيرات يعني مثلا هنا في فرنسا هناك
اقبال شديد على مبيعات
باربي دميه باربي في المحلات يعني ارتفاع
مهول في المبيعات
يمكن ايقونه نسويه لطبقه معينه ولكن لازم
يعني لا ننسى ان من من يص
هم عاملات ذو اجور جد قليله في الصين يعني
75% من الدول اليوم باربي مصنوعه في الصين
وهذا الشيء يعني انا بالنسبه لي هذا
النسويه لا تمثلني النسويه التي
يعني
على حساب على حسابي على حساب عاملات في
دول اخرى دول يكون فيها يعني
دول ديكتاتوريه ولا دول فيها قمع للنساء
وانا بالنسبه لي اليوم النسويه ليست نسويه
ان نكون ما نريد او ما نشاء هي نشويه ان
ان نسائنا لا تقتل ان النساؤنا تجد يعني
الكرامه والحي والعيش الكريم يعني فانا
بالنسبه للقضايا الواقعيه هي ابعد بكثير
عن الفانتازيا التي يمكن ان نراها في في
علم حتى لو يعني هذا يمكن اول فيلم
اخرجته مخرجه
سيده سيده ويحقق ويحقق هذه الارباح ولكن
هذا هذه النسويه لا تمثلني ولا تمثل شريحه
كبيره من النساء
نهايه ساذهب اليك بعد قليل ولكن عندي سؤال
لك يعني كتبت شيئا استوقفني قلت باربي
وغيره من الافلام التي على هذا النمط دليل
فاقع على المازق الذي يعاني منه الغرب
حاليا وهوليوت في الصداره قد يملك بعضهم
مشروعا نقديا مقبولا لكنهم لا يملكون
حكايات يمررون بها افكارهم عمليه الاصلاح
لديهم بتتمر عبر الماضي وعبر اعمال
الاخرين خصوصا هلا فسرت لنا هذه الفكره
قليلا لانها مهمه خلينا نحكي مثلا عن
موضوع
البياض الناصع
بالانجليزي
بياض الثلج والاقسام السبعه
اخذوا هالفكره هيدي وغيروها كلها ما بقى
في شيء من القصه الاصليه لانه
القصص اللي كانت تنحكى قبل تعرضت لتحديث
يعني ما اليوم بمعايير المجتمعات الغربيه
الحديثه من حقوق
بسور قبل يعني ما في واحد يلغي تاريخه
لانه هيدي كمان هالقصص فادتنا ونوصل لهون
يعني مثل درج هو الموضوع نطلع على درجه
درجه بعدين
ربما لا داعي تبييض صوره باربي اليوم رجب
خلق شخصيات جديده برايك بس باربي يعني مش
مستهلك مثل هديك مش انه نعمل افلام عن
باربي قبل انه قال عم بيغيروا باربي باربي
لعبه تجاريه سلعه يعني الباربي مش فن
بينما يديك الحكايات اللي عم بيجربوا
يغيروها كلها بالنهايه ما ضل في شي منا
يعني بس مشان يستفيدوا من الاسم ويرجعوا
يبيعوا ويرجعوا ينتشروا
ليه ما عندهم حكايات هن يخلقوا حكايات
من خلال نظرياته او
الافكار الجديده اللي بدهن يفوتوها على
المجتمع طيب
ساذهب اليك مهاد قبل يعني لانه سينتهي
الوقت قبل ان نختم ساعود الى فكره يعني
الفكره التي اليوم تناقش كثيرا في الدول
التي عرضت الفيلم وهي فكره النسويه يعني
اليوم هل يمكن في مكان ما ان نرى
ايجابيه لقضايا النساء في افلام قد تكون
هكذا هل يمكن اليوم ان تصبح الافلام
الترفيهيه ايضا منبرا لمساعده النساء
اميمه تقول لا ترى شيئا نسبيا في هذا
الفيلم يمكن ان تكون نسويه هكذا هل
توافقين
هلا بغض النظر انه انا شفت النسويه اللي
عم بتقدمها
بقدمها الفيلم هي نسويه الليبراليه اكثر
ميلا من انه تكون نسويه تقاطعيه خاصه لما
حيكون عن انه جميع باربي الباربيات
متشابهات ولو كانوا عم يظهروا انه لا في
اختلاف بيناتهم بس هذا ما كان كافر لانه
منلاحظ مثلا بمكان ما انه عمليه التغيير
كانت من خلال انه باربي بتحكي لباربي تاني
عن نقاط قوتها او عن مضيقك بهذه المدينه
يعني المثاليه هذا الشيء بيشبه بعمليه
تمكين المراه وهذا المصطلح او التوعيه
النساء وهذا المصطلحق شوي اشكالي
الاوساط النسويه انه مين نحن حتى نكون عم
نمكن النساء انه نحن بدنا نكون قراب
لقضايا نساء بدنا نكون عم جد عم نفهم هن
شو عم بيعانوا شو المعاناه اليوميه اللي
عم بيعيشوا فيها وانه تمكين منه شيء كافي
انه كمان
نفس الوقت بنشوف انه الفيلم
فرجها هشاشه المجتمع او العالم عالم
الرجال نحن عالمنا اليوم هو عالم رجال
يعني اللي صانعينه واللقاء قديم في كل
الرجال ما في انه جدا جدا
حياه الناس
وثائقي وليس لا حتى
هو فيلم ابعد ما يمكن هو فيلم الواقع هو
يعني مرسوم يكاد يكون في تحريك يعني
الوان واشكال اشكال جميله ناس ما عندهم
عيوب او عندهم عيوب بس لانه الكاتب
السيناري قرر انه مش ناس حقيقيين
خلص الوقت لانه بس عندي سؤال بسيط
الاء باختصار ومن ثم اميمه عن الانوثه
والنسويه اليوم هناك ايضا هذا الجدل حول
باربي وشخصيه باربي وكيف يمكن هل يمكن
لباربي ان تتحول من الان الى النسويه ام
ان تتكامل هذه القصه باختصار لو سمحتي لا
لا
انا برايي انه ما في شكل واحد للنسويه
اكيد ممكن انها تتكامل ممكن انها تكون
يعني الموضوع مبتعد اذا بدنا نحط حسب يعني
انا فرضت انه عم تقولي انه الانوثه هي شكل
باربي الكلي الشاي لهذا البيرفكت مزبوط
يعني
طيب لانه اليوم يعني
لا باختصار لانه خلص الوقت جمله يلا يلا
جمله واحده بدي اقول انه بس لما عم نحكي
عن موضوع النسويه انه تغيير مسار الشركه
من عام 2015 وانتاجها باربيات متنوعه
والنساء الملهمه والحديث معناه النسويه
بفين باربي هو برايي انتصار للنسويه بغض
النظر عن هذا الفيلم هو
بعتقد وجود اربع نساء ورجل اكثر
ولكن النسويه هي اليوم هو يعني مساواه على
جميع
الصعود بين الرجل والمراه والاشخاص
الاشخاص الذين يعبرون عن نفسهم خارج هذه
الانماط الفكريه يعني في الاخير الانوثه
مهمه ولكن ليس هي الوحيده يعني شكرا
للجميع اختم مع مقوله للنسويه الفرنسيه
الكاتبه والصحفيه والسياسيه حين قالت
الانوثه ليست عجزا لكن في نفس الوقت هي
ليست معيارا للكفاءه والنقاش الفلكي
الممنوع لا نهايه له نترك لك ولك حريه
الاختيار وحريه التفكير الى اللقاء في
حلقات جديده على شاشه واثير اذاعه الدوليه
تحياتي
[موسيقى]